so new game against Caro fun from
Germany so D hab g
bit
well the Laska variant is
of course very remirable so
let's do
B6
tatakova a bit of an unusual
move order now to
swap white of
course
nothing bad has
happened but of course it's not that
ambitious
Of course, it's not exactly a
position where Black could
do so much
after
C5. I'll have to play it at some point. It's
a very balanced position. Well,
now he's moved E4,
thankfully not that it
's bad, but that at least gives it
a bit of asymmetry  Let's take a
look at the position, sometimes you can
play knight D7 in such a position. CB knight C5
D A3 ne probably isn't good, okay,
so just capture it, well, well,
E4 is just a bit of a
weakening. It weakens the black
squares a bit and makes the
bishop penti
bad so now yes now I can
just take E4 no
or is it somehow a trick Bishop E4 Bishop
D7 well no special trick actually
or D A4 or something like that
nope
not like
that Queen
die7 yes well of
course you have oh so I thought he
might swap and  destroys my
pawn position,
so you can just play that
and say you have a giant bishop
on
d5, yes, you can
rightly do that,
knight E5, it's the last
active idea he still
has,
so if he plays knight E5 now, it
might work  Queen runner
G2 yes, a runner G2 is also possible.
I also have rook D7.
E5 pushes it directly into it
yes we can take away and then
maybe
A5 the bishop always covers
the rook nicely here
that came rook
C1
yes the
b pawn has to do the race
so
yes but here I also have the
intermediate move ne to cover the B5
so
arrested
so  There are some other tricks
knight E7 or something like that, well first of all
take away the rook that ca
n't be wrong here
check
like that and then he probably has to
play Queen E3 then D a no you get
in there Queen A1 Chess King F2 Queen B2
wins  the knight or
yes wins the
knight somehow even more powerfully probably won't work no no well well
knight is
also a knight no
so he's probably seen now too
well actually give up
colleague
so he's hanging he's hanging too but I
can just
take
check
check  yes, that should also be ready in a minute
time
warning
check I'm playing it stupidly no, so
if I now check out queen8, well it
still doesn't work
but
like that
Check now you can't
set Pat in a stupid way
Check
Checkmate
okay yes that  It worked quite well but I
just
put it away